it is late and I am sleepy but I feel
strangely motivated to do SAT problems
so I will do SAT problems so we'll start
a new test
it's gonna be test 2 and and we're gonna
start on section 3 and that's the on
page 459 of the said book called the
official SAT study guide by the College
Board so let's get started so the first
problem problem number 1 it said if 3 B
plus 1 is less than 10 which of the
following can not be the value of B so
which is long cannot be the value of B
and they gave a couple of choices a
minus 1 B 0 C 1 D 2 e 3 and you could I
mean really you could start with choice
a and just keep going through all of
them and inspect it really fast I mean
the way I would do is I would
automatically convert this equation
subtract 1 from both sides and you say
well this is the same thing as 3 times B
has to be less than 9 I just subtracted
1 from both sides of this right and if
you look at these well 3 times negative
1 that's negative 3 that's less than 9 3
times 0 that's 0 that's less than 9 let
me write that 3 times negative 1 is
negative 3 3 times 0 is 0
3 times 1 is 3 3 times 2 is 6 these are
all less than 9 right I just substitute
each of these for B but 3 times 3 that
is actually equal to 9 right 3 times 3
is equal to 9 which is not less than 9
so our choice is e number 2 I think I
have space to do it on this without
having to clear the chalkboard it says 2
to the 4x is equal to 16 whenever you
see one of these problems where the
variable is in the exponent and you have
different bases here the trick is really
just to convert them to the same base so
can I write 16 as a power of 2 well sure
what's 2 to the what power 16 well due
to the squared is 4 2/3
the third power is 8 to the 4th power is
16 right so we could write this same
equation as 2 to the 4x it's equal to
another way of writing 16 is 2 to the
fourth power right and now this should
this this should seem a little bit more
straightforward 2 to the 4x is the same
thing as 2 to the fourth so 4 X must
equal 4 right 4 X must equal 4 and so X
is equal to 1 and that choice exists so
I feel confident in my answer let's move
on I think I might be coming down with
the flu
let's hope not because that would limit
my ability to turn out SAT problems on
YouTube
number 3 how much greater is our - -
than our plus 5 our minus 2 then our
plus 5 well if I wanted to know how much
one number is greater than another if I
asked you how much greater is you know
10 then 5 what do I do
well I take 10 minus 5 and that's my
answer so example 10 minus 5 is 5 so 10
is 5 greater than 5 right so if I want
to know how much greater then R minus 2
is R plus 5 right and R plus 5 is going
to be the greater one you just subtract
them so we say R plus 5 minus R minus 2
so R plus 5 minus R I'm just
distributing the negative number plus 2
the R is cancel out and you get the
answer it's 7 and you really didn't even
have to do it this way because this R
could be any number and it should the
answer should be the same no matter what
R is and obviously it worked out because
the RS cancelled out but the easiest
thing would be list and let me just
assume that R is 0 because we can cuz
you know it shouldn't matter what R is
so far was 0 then the question is how
much how much greater what is it how
much greater
then negative 2 is +5 right I just
assumed that R is 0 and then you would
do the same thing you'd do 5 minus
negative 2 which is equal to 7 and you
could draw them on the number line if if
you wanted to visually approach to this
problem all right this next problem this
one looks visual problem number 4 ok so
it has a square it looks at me I kind of
need to draw it fancy let me just draw
it freehand because so it's a box it
looks like this they say that the box is
open at the top the box is open at the
top so that's the bottom right there
okay and they give measurements this end
is 4
this end is 3 and then the height is 2
and then they were say if we were to
essentially you know cut the sides of
this box and then flatten it all out
which of these choices are that this box
this is a pure visualization problem but
to flatten it out as I said you would
cut these this line you would cut this
line like I'm just imagining what I
would do with had some scissors and
there's no top to the box right and then
I would take this side and I would
flatten it out that way this side I
would flatten it out that way that back
side I'll flatten it out there and
that's that I'll flatten it out there
and so what would be I left so you'd
have the base so the base would look
like this where you have three would be
this kind of the width right this side
this side corresponds to this side right
this side
would correspond to this side and that
would be of length four and then this
height to let me draw that
so this flap which I draw in brown that
flap would come out like this would come
out flat like that and this this
distance right here would be two and
then you would have another let's say
this flap in the back let me draw it in
another color draw in a dark purple just
flap in the back would come out like
this flat it would also have two lengths
and then the other two flaps like this
one this flap would come out like this
and of course just that's two here then
finally I have that flap in the back you
know this flap in the back come out like
that all right no she ate it did like I
shaded it in the original picture and
that would also have to so this is a
pure visualization problem hopefully
there's not a lot more that I can do to
explain this and you know there's no top
to this box and then we had a we had a
bottom and this would look like so this
is the choice see if we if we rotated it
around a little bit
it's choice E they actually rotated
around because choice he looks like this
choice a looks like choice e looks like
this I'm not drawing it that well but it
looks something like this where they say
that this length is 4 this length is 2
than this length is 3 so they took this
and they essentially rotated it so that
this side becomes this side and then
this side becomes that side so they just
rotated it clockwise about what is that
a little over 90 degrees and that's how
they got that answer so there's a pure
visualization problem with that I have
about 90 seconds left in this video so
I'll wait to do it in the next video
I'll
you soon